[Music]
hi
welcome the setup for today is that we
are going to do a brief introduction
we will quickly jump into introducing
our panelists as well as
the q a um we are here for you to answer
your questions
so feel free any time to start throwing
those questions into the q
a box um and we get to that portion we
will get to those
you can use the upvoting feature which
is a little thumbs up button
in your zoom panel and that will help me
know
which questions are of most interest to
everybody here and so we can make sure
that we get to those
as i said you know our students are
have a diverse range of interests and
passions they go on to
various fields and injured industries
we're here today to talk about
media entertainment which actually is
tied for our fifth most popular
industry in terms of careers upon
graduation and we have
a diverse and dynamic group of alums
from the arts media entertainment world
joining us today
with no further ado i will let them
introduce themselves
so why don't we start with i'm just
going to go with who i see down my
screen so mike if you want to take it
away
hi everyone thanks for joining great to
be here with you virtually
my name is mike i just graduated from
the gsb in june
which is kind of hard to believe that
that's that's already the case
um i um went to washu in st
louis um for undergrad did i freeze on
your stream
yeah we can hear you but i think you're
frozen
oh maybe mike is having connection
issues let's jump to
um helen while he gets that sorted out
hey everyone i'm helen i graduated in
2019
from the gsb i um
before business school i worked in
sports
at the national basketball association
in strategy
and then um now i work at spotify
um yeah i think that's are we supposed
to say anything else
nope that's good cool
showing through myself yep
hi guys my name is alberto santini i'm
from mexico
i to undergrad a university montana
mexico
i got to hold two bachelor's degree and
i got
also a degree in arts and drama and
entertainment
and before i joined the gsb i was an
actor
and i wanted to become an executive so
that's why i
started to to pursue my goal to enter to
the gsb awesome steve
yeah hello everybody um uh my name is
steve class of 2007.
uh congratulations by the way to all of
you i believe
all of you have been admitted right no
sorry these are all this is prospects
steve
oh prospects okay i'm sorry so well
future congratulations to those of you
who can join the community yeah exactly
i i received my undergrad at harvard
uh and prior to the gsb uh spent a
couple years in investment banking in
new york
for goldman sachs and then went to china
for a couple of years
to do a startup media company i'm
currently
the chief growth officer at fox
corporation
and when i was at the gsp i had actually
no
intent or desire to be in media but um i
find myself uh there now uh which sort
of
uh speaks to the preparation i think the
gsb gives broadly um to whatever you may
want to pursue in the future so that's
me
awesome um ali hi everyone i'm ali
um i went to stanford undergrad i'm
originally from california as well
um and before the gsb i worked in
entertainment i worked at netflix
um then went to the gsb and just
graduated in june like mike
and now i'm working at masterclass um
she's also
adjacent to media in san francisco
great and mike we can see you now so
i'm using my new work computer which
apparently uh has some some issues but
hopefully that doesn't happen again
um yeah so i graduated ali's class uh
just a couple months ago
i went to washu in st louis was a film
and finance major
i was always trying to figure out if i
wanted to be on the business or the
creative side of the industry
i did strategy consulting for a few
years then worked for an entertainment
rental company in la we did the
equipment for coachella and
uh you know camera rentals for movies
and stuff like that
and um then came the gsb and and now
just started a new job at evolution
media capital which is caa's
investment bank wonderful
so we've got great representation here
so if you guys are
feel free you have any questions for any
of our specific panelists about their
specific path um or just general
questions feel free to throw them in i
will kick it off
with um sort of the a big question
which is you know arts media
entertainment
it's not the first thing that people
think of when they think of someone with
an mba
so for you i'll individually ask for
this for everybody to kick off
what made you think of pursuing an mba
to begin with and why stanford so let's
start with alberto
yeah well rather interesting you know
coming from mexico
and i always wanted to to be executive
television since i was 10 years old i
was involved in getting
programming content i was develop
developing my own content whatever
so um because my family is not related
with the media
and i don't have anybody at that time to
relate with the media when i was
when i finished uh university
i approached to to a tv company the main
uh the leading tv company in latin
america which is televisa
because i wanted to pursue a career as
an executive
at the end i ended being an actor there
was a casting
you said and i thought maybe this is the
only opportunity i can get to
to get into the media right so there was
25 000 people
online so i was one of the 25 that they
picked
thanks scott i started to to take some
classes in there in the co
in the course so uh
at that point i started to do soap
operas and i started to post some tv
tv shows another time is when i thought
this is the time for me
to pursue my mba at stanford university
so i can reach my goal since i was a kid
to be an executive of the media
entertainment company so and that's why
i started to
to i decided to stand for i look for
different options
but it's time for uh uh had everything
that i wanted
you know i even visited harvard i did
everything all the universities were
beautiful they were nice
very professional but staff were
specifically
it has everything you know at least for
me you know and
my experience there was awesome awesome
we love we love to hear that
um helen i'm sorry but eventually i
become the ceo of the second largest
spanish television world which is stevia
you know so i i i stumbled what's the
path you know
to get to my goal yeah we'll talk a
little bit about sort of uh what how
stamper prepared you for that career
um helen what about you in terms of you
know what made you leave the nba
why an mba why this time why stanford
um i was thinking about
going to get going to business school
mostly because
i wanted like a good two-year
time to be able to self-reflect and
develop like leadership skills soft
skills
and i think that's also why the gsb was
a clear choice for me too
because i had gone to undergrad business
school so i wasn't looking for
hardcore like accounting marketing
finance
um classes and i also worked in finance
before the mba so it was really like
finding a program that i felt like i can
develop
personally um and have those kind of
soft skills in the classes like
touchy-feely doing talks
at the gsb all of those are really
reasons that i felt like i can
um where i felt like i could learn the
most grow the most
and get the most out of the two years so
and steve you came from investment
banking so an mba may have been a more
traditional path um but i'd love to hear
why
you chose stamford and then we'll talk a
little bit about what made you
do the pivot
yeah maybe mine's a little bit more
complex
i actually came to the gsb not with with
the media was the last thing i wanted to
do
probably um but you know
my thesis for me going into the gsb was
uh one what what an amazing group of
caring um smart and passionate people
who want to change the world
and i think if you get 350 400 people
who think like that the world will
change
and so that was really the biggest draw
for me uh but as i sort of
traversed the two years and did a couple
of other things
my goal was actually to go into public
service i wanted to actually take the
efficiencies of
business and applied to government
processes and
and policy and so one thing led to
another i had a little internship
at the cia's venture capital firm
called incutel when i was at the bay
area
uh which opened my eyes to venture
capital um
again which i i really didn't have any
idea what venture capital was
uh to be honest with you coming in even
though i was an investment banker
um but i think really retro respectively
it's probably the best decision i've
made uh in my life in terms of an
academic training because
especially in media these days and
especially the role i
am now where i'm looking at growth
opportunities for media
technology is such a key part of what we
do
so whether it's a streaming platform or
the user experience or
you know an algorithm to to give you the
best recommendations
all the media companies now are becoming
and forced to become tech companies and
so i think just the
the the nature of stanford and where we
are in silicon valley and
just the the amount of resources and and
and sort of
insight you get from in the classroom
and outside
um i think is invaluable for what a
media company should look like in 10 to
20 years especially
so anyway so it's a little bit of a you
know retrospective on the the
my decision but looking back um i think
there's no better place
to prepare yourself for life and media
because of that technology core that
stanford can offer you
that's great um and mike and ali are two
most recent grads
who wants to jump in i'm happy to start
um
yeah so for me i knew long term i wanted
to be a general manager
in entertainment and for some sort of
content business
and i knew to be a general manager i
need a broader skill set than what i was
getting in consulting or in like a
corporate strategy function
so things like negotiations some more
finance experience
marketing operations those are some of
the hard skills i wanted to build
um and probably more importantly i
wanted to build more leadership skills
you know i'd managed a few people
uh before but i hadn't had a lot of
experience like
giving feedback really managing a team
and and stanford sort of
soft skills as helen said are probably
the best program out there for that
so that really attracted me also my boss
at the time was a gsb alum and
he uh shared you know all these amazing
experiences and
made me really want to go
yeah mine is very similar to mike i um i
felt like i needed more
of the hard skills because i wanted to
be an executive in media i was ready in
media
but i felt like i had majored in biology
in college and didn't have a lot of
those
business foundation that i felt like i
would need later on
and also wanted to sharpen and be more
focused on my leadership and
communication skills and i feel like
those two years
were great um time to do that so
same and also in my team there were
quite a few gsb alums so that
um definitely definitely encouraged me
yeah um we're heavy on influencing more
people in so
brayden asked actually a question that i
had for you guys as well which was
how has an mba helped you in the
entertainment industry right so
so what are some of the ways that you
have seen the skills the
lessons the education you know the
curriculum have you seen that being a
of an mba being applied in this space
this one i'll throw it to anybody who
wants to take that one
let me maybe i'll start i think i think
mike and ali
mentioned it but i think more than maybe
any other business media
really is about people it's about the
creativity and
and how to draw out the intangibles in
people
for a creative and um and and sort of
the delightful output
that gets to entertain and inform the
world
and i think for me i think helen you
mentioned touchy-feely
it's kind of what we used to call this
interpersonal dynamics
force where you're essentially in a
small group
of people who sign nda basically
and are able to give you direct feedback
about
how you say things what you say and to a
level
and depth that cannot be paralleled by
any other experience in my
in my life and that kind of soft skill
training
of people who care about you but are
willing to give you candid feedback
about
so many different aspects of your
communication style etc
i think those are the skill sets at the
end of the day that i rely on most
especially in the media business where
you have a lot of personalities and
egos and you know creativity and
you just you know there's no sort of
textbook way to handle things because
every issue is so different
so for me that was the most
helpful sort of skill set i was able to
build and not only is it in that
classroom but you take
those kinds of values out to outside the
classroom as you interact with your
classmates
and the community at large stanford is a
very open
sort of warm and caring group
and so i think those kinds of things
stuck with me
as i went into the media world so that's
what i would say
happy to quickly jump in um totally
agree with what steve said
um another example sort of on the other
end of the spectrum
is uh you know on on hard skills so i
took
uh peter dimarzo's financial modeling
class uh
the spring of my first year which is
like basically an investment banking
training program you do
you know m a models you do lbo models
starting with like
basics for people who have never really
used excel before
and so by the end of that class i felt
like i was pretty dangerous
um in excel and then when i went to my
internships i was like able to apply
that right away and
i think do some pretty good work as a
result and
no doubt that's helped me you know get
my job now where i'm doing a lot of that
um where before i didn't really have
that classic training to
be able to you know be confident in
excel
well in my case uh adding a little bit
of
what i have been saying uh for me was uh
once again coming from mexico and and uh
uh learning in uh and knowing that i was
gonna be sharing
with uh uh peers from different parts of
the world
it will open my my my my view
that what i can do uh coming to stamp or
so
i learn a lot of things in istanbul you
know and and
you learn every every single day and at
the end he helped me
i wanted to become an executive and i
didn't have enough the background
finance
and business and me i knew it and and i
was ready to
to get to the next stage so it was a
challenge also for me uh
when i was in mexico they accepted
probably like
six people six mexicans i was one of
them
and uh but yeah i wanted also to study
it was in silicon valley
you know it was in 99 you know i'm older
but you guys
so uh everything was coming along you
know with the
with the uh with the internet with
everything so stuff was in
in in silicon valley so this is the
place to be and uh i didn't make a
mistake you know and
i uh that's why i decided to be there
and i
learned a lot through my peers you know
i think um sorry go ahead i'm just
because i i recently switched jobs so
it's very fresh was like
um i think having an mba
uh allowed me to get a much higher
paying role
maybe not a me i immediately after
business school for sure but then also
like it just continues to build and i
think that was very
evident in this most most recent
recruiting cycle and then
also while i was recruiting i was able
to um
basically email all the alumni that
works that
work at spotify right now and they were
all willing to talk to me about
the interview process about their
experience etc so like that gsp network
even though i had never met any of those
people before
still lives on even though you graduate
and i think it gets stronger and
stronger
as more and more people graduate and
join the network so
those are just a couple of examples of
how the gsb
continues to help me even i mean i've
only
graduated two years ago but it just it
adds on over time and i didn't even
realize some of like
the awesome like pull that it has
even now so yeah um
[Music]
speaking of recruiting mike and ali
since you guys are most recent sort of
have gone through that process
katie um penmental asked a question
about
how was your recruiting experience
different from maybe your classmates in
other
you know consulting finance more
traditional mba
um industries and how did the gsp
support you
through the recruiting process and what
was the most valuable resource
definitely yeah i can take it um
so i would say for media and
entertainment broadly it can really vary
there are some recruiting processes from
bigger media companies like your tech
companies like netflix and hulu
or your disney um hbo warner
that have very set recruiting processes
and look a lot like consulting and
banking they recruit on campus
they have a set deadline and you you
kind of know the process pretty well and
the career center can help you a lot
with that my process was a little bit
more focused on smaller companies and
that meant
it was more self-led so the way the
career center
supported me on that was um my career
advisor worked with me very closely on
which alums i should reach out to in the
in the industry
um help me connect with them and what i
should ask about and
what other types of roles um students
before me have gotten in that industry
so that one was more me reaching out to
people and finding opportunities but i
still got a lot of support from the
career center
yeah i totally agree with ali's
experience um
i think for me another element was i
didn't really know what function i was
looking for like i was doing a lot of
research
including everything from like you know
more of the traditional like corporate
strategy of warner brothers roles but
also like
being the business person to a producer
and seeing if i like that
that kind of role which is not
structured and that is totally just
based on
uh reaching out to folks so i'd say i
did like 80
80 of my search was reaching out to
people proactively
working with my career advisor to figure
out who who would be good
and then the other 20 was postings on
career hub
um and sort of more formal recruiting
processes
um and mike and steve you guys both
alluded a little bit to
the uh some courses but both colter and
ustra are asking classes about what some
of the most popular courses or student
art
or organizations are that students are
interested
in arts entertainment might explore um
as well as are there any classes at the
gsb that are focused on
media entertainment that gives people an
opportunity to
explore the creative side or get a
holistic view of the industry
so open that one up to anybody who wants
to chat about either
courses or student clubs and activities
well i would say something i mean uh it
was funny but one of my
favorite courses at stanford was the
interpersonal dynamic the
billy class you know i mean sometimes
people don't think about it but you
learn a lot you know and
and uh during that class you know i made
my
uh my very close friends for life and
you
understand how to uh manage more
human resources once that you are in a
position you know that you are going to
be handling
so that's one of my favorite courses
most of the courses you don't find is
economy
well you study in underground
you have other opportunities but those
type of classes at least for me i
thought you feel the class
it's funny but that i i have a very good
memory for them
that was my favorite class
yeah i talked a little bit about the
club side of things um
so ali and i were both on the leadership
team of the arts media entertainment
club
uh which was impacted a little bit with
kovid but
um we still did a lot of fireside chats
with executives
we did a um like two sessions that were
like an la trek normally we would fly to
la and meet with companies but we did it
all on zoom
so we met with netflix and amazon and
spotify sort of all the major
you know players in the space so that's
more like recruiting resources that we
provide
um we also did like you know social
events and
stuff like that um the other sort of
entertainment related club that's less
i'd say career oriented but more fun as
as i was
one of the directors of the gsb show
which is an annual
normally a live play that we put on in
front of you know a thousand people but
because of kobit we made a two hour
movie
uh with over 100 people you know in the
cast and crew
so uh if you're interested in production
or want to have a little more of a
creative outlet
that's uh that was definitely the
highlight of my gsp experience
the gsb show's awesome you should watch
it on youtube
this is on youtube yeah highly recommend
it mostly inside jokes
uh there there is a um a class that
is and i the name has evolved so i don't
know what it's called anymore
but but it's uh professor bertelman um
at the corp it's about corporate
strategy and the theme of the class is
you know in a large corporation where
you've got sort of a core business
and you have new ideas you know how do
you get innovation through
to through in large corporations and the
lesson from that class i've taken with
me in
you know all the past like four jobs
i've had
uh including this one of how do you
fight against the the machine within
your own corporation
no matter how innovative uh that company
is once you get to be a side there's
sort of a core
function and core business but in the
media or tech space there's always
you've got to disrupt yourself and so
there's some great frameworks and
uh and and through you know guest
speakers at the ceo at the board level
uh guest speakers coming in uh through
the whole quarter
talking about how to get innovation
through large corporations
um and that that's an invaluable one
that i take with me
even to this day
if i may say something i'm sorry another
thing that was very interesting was
when i was at stanford remember i wasn't
99 you know class so
right now there are more classes i mean
courses and new courses
but at that time and not just the
faculty staff and the professor
they were teaching us but also they
invited uh
bill gates they invited warren buffett
once uh in my
economy class so that type of
personalities leaders
of or in those
fields you know it motivates all the
students you know
watching walking into your class uh
wearing bluff at you know he's like wow
oh bill gates would want to to even
speech over there
you know so that is also very valuable
for
for me
um ally were you going to say something
yeah um i completely agree about
a lot of my favorite classes had were
just very focused on guest speakers
and the two had mentioned is there's one
called leadership
leadership in the entertainment industry
and that brings in
every type of role in the entertainment
industry from the business side people
who are
c-level warner disney
also to producers actors different types
of people to ask them about their
leadership experience in the
entertainment industry
and it's basically a q a format where
students ask these
great leaders any questions and then one
of my other favorite classes is called
managing growing enterprises and that's
really focused on developing you as a
people manager
and i've been using that a ton in my job
recently just
how to have a how to give feedback to
someone how to hire how to think about
building your team just very um
great uh takeaways from that class and
that was a lot of
speakers coming in and talking about how
they did it in their own companies
and i will do a plug too for um so we
really encourage interdisciplinary
learning here at the gsb
so all of our students are encouraged to
take classes
across all of stamford's campus so you
can actually take a class
in any school at stanford and
get um credit that goes towards your um
degree
um so if you did want if you were
interested in something in like the
creative writing or you know media arts
or something like that it's somewhere
else you're welcome to actually take
that class and get that exposure
um nicole uh i love her question
can you describe your best and worst day
at the gsb and alberto was it when you
met warren buffett i'm just i'm kidding
no no no actually because they they were
a lot of
guest speakers you know not just in the
auditorium but also in the class it was
amazing everybody that i met
you know and uh but yeah that was one of
the
the the good things that i had when i
was there
um but uh what is the the best days
i mean is when uh after exams you know
that
we made parties you know we never forgot
that you know because uh one week two
weeks prior to that we were
uh working so hard you know to get the
the best great uh grades
and but the the worst part when i was
there is because
the first year i was doing so hard you
know to
to three one of the
first uh top ten in the class and i was
like
starting a story so the second year i
find out that
i could have meeting more people having
more friends
uh and i wasted that time you know so
the second year of course
i was just normal i tried to to to build
friendship with everybody
and i was not pressured to be one of the
top 10 you know so
my recommendation is just to to relax
you know study hard
but uh take advantage of those two years
that are wonderful
and the people you are going to be
meeting there they are going to be
wonderful you know for the rest of your
life
um anyone else want to make the steve
best
no the worst day is when you have to get
out of uh stanford
um you know the last day because i think
we
are such a unique experience
but i think you know you alluded to this
journal it's it's
a lot of it is um you know stanford
if you if you if you make a parallel to
software it's like
it's like open source software you know
versus
a closed software where um
you know stanford's got so many
resources and you know it's
interdisciplinary and you've got
wonderful people it's just like
you have all of these ingredients and
you know i think
stanford may not be the best place for
somebody who wants to
sort of get fed an institutionalized
you know recipe for some output you know
maybe there are some better schools for
that
but if you um want to explore and sort
of create
you know that song sort of your my way
like if you
if you have a vision of what your you
want to make
i can't think of a better place than
stanford that can give you that
support and resource and the alumni you
know now having been an alumni
i guess i'm a little younger than
alberto and a little older than some of
the others but
i i've been on the receiving end of
emails
of people wanting to talk to me or
getting advice etc
and i can tell you i always write back
uh and i think
i'm reciprocating my experience you know
10 years ago or whatever
that it was me asking for help and i got
uh
every call back as well and i think
that's the kind of camaraderie
at the school and after the school and
and that's something very very special
especially in a school that's so
resourceful yet so small relatively
that can create that kind of an
environment which i think is very unique
to us
yeah exciting
something as well that is very
interesting very valuable
it was amazing like in every single
class
that we had we have the same case
analysis
but uh the paths that every single study
group
reached their goal was different so you
were learning
how my my friend my classmates from
india
or my classmates from germany or my
classmates from argentina
we're doing the same case analysis but
with different approaches
and that's very valuable as well you
know open your mind open your
your options you know when you are in a
position that you have to make decisions
in addition to the friendship of course
um okay so uh pivoting
back to then some questions about
career preparation so i'm scrolling
through some of the questions here that
i'm seeing in the q
a so for those of you who made an
industry pivot so i
will call out steve mike
and helen i think um what resources or
what specifically was crucial
um in terms of your gsb experience that
helped you do that
i think for me what i found really
helpful
um even though i was i was kind of
pivoting
um from sports to media
music more traditional entertainment and
i found the career services really
helpful
um grace is amazing i still email her to
this day
and she was able to kind of
i think ali touched upon this or just
like kind of talk you through
how what you're thinking and give you
options connect you with alumni that
have been going through this
or are working in that field and i found
that super helpful so i think
that for me was probably one of the most
helpful and then i think in general just
the network again like during business
school i use that as my as an
opportunity to talk to
as many people as possible in all
different
roles within the media and entertainment
industry
and a lot of those conversations i mean
obviously didn't go anywhere besides
just teaching me
about what they did um and i think that
helped
a lot to understand what roles i wanted
to do what roles i didn't want to do
because i also pivoted roles i worked in
strategy before and now i work in
partnerships and business development
which i had no skill set for
um but was able to kind of understand
that role and really develop that
through the role itself so i think it
really just opens opportunities and gave
me the experience
to learn as much as possible and use
like the gsp
as a reason
and i i think on that like you can pivot
your function you can pivot your
industry or or both
um if you're pivoting function that's
the cmc the career center does a really
good job of
they have like panels pretty early on
where you talk to alumni about like the
pivot
functionally and so that's applicable
across a lot of different industries
um on the industry side i think the
alumni network was just
really invaluable as as helen said and
just one example for me is
my gsb interview was with someone in the
entertainment industry in la i think
they try to pair you with someone who's
like
you know has your you know aspirations
or has achieved your aspirations in some
ways
and so once i got in i stayed in touch
with him and he was really helpful for
me and introduced me to some other
people
um so like alumni are everywhere and as
steve said earlier like
everyone's always responsive and helps
you sort of think through different
options
and steve what about you because as
you've um mentioned a couple times you
came in from investment banking and
media was sort of the last
thing on your mind what resources um
were crucial in your career
trajectory if you will then for post gsb
yeah and i think there's a recurring
theme here i think the alumni resource
and not that there's just an alumni
resource but that they're very
responsive and engaged right
because it's one thing to have a bunch
of names on a yellow pages but
you know it's another thing to actually
be able to engage and get help
um so for me they were just there at
every turn in terms of
my serendipitous walk to where i am
today
uh there's always seems to be some gsb
resource that's
sort of critical for me at the time so i
try to do the same thing and giving back
now
but yeah it is that engaged alumni
network and the fact is if
there isn't somebody directly helpful to
you there is
you know 99.9 chance that somebody can
put you in touch with that person
uh from the stanford network so whether
it's the first or second degree
connection
uh i think just stanford is unparalleled
in the way that it has its
tentacles and deep quality introductions
to what you need to
and to where you need to get to um so i
think that that was really it for me
um marielle has a question um i think
a good one thanks for asking uh if
if any of you were able to personalize
your trajectory at the gsb
towards exploration um if you didn't
know you'd end up in
arts media entertainment or towards
ame if you knew that that's what you
wanted to do
so like if you and you guys wanna maybe
go through sort of what your
gs two years experience was like and and
um
how you were able to sort of personalize
or customize that path
v you know into arts media entertainment
and in what different ways
yeah i'm happy to start with that uh so
you know i was coming from
a production services company so a
little bit on the outskirts of the
the industry in some ways um and i
wanted to get
you know try out different things across
um
the industry and so i um i did want to
try out being like a business person to
a producer and there's a gsb alum who's
a
pretty um well well-regarded film
producer he did the kids are all right
and a few other sort of more indie
movies and so i i did like a part-time
internship with him
um helping him raise money for his
production company and also like reading
scripts and doing some creative
so that was like a really easy way for
me to test that that out
i also sort of like everybody else at
stanford had some
aspirations for doing a startup and
i actually did a class with ali called
startup garage where
we tested out an idea in the
entertainment uh industry which was
really fun and really
insightful and i also interned with an
early stage
streaming company uh last summer um
that was you know series a so very early
stage and got got sort of the streaming
experience as well as the startup
experience
and then finally i got to the banking
side of things where
i did like a part-time internship in the
spring right before i graduated with
with evolution
um and so i guess across the two years i
was able to do
you know early stage startup streaming
production and
investment banking all sort of related
to entertainment so i think
business school is really the only time
you can you can take that kind of
exploration
those are great examples um anyone else
want to talk about
their personal path or
through the gsb well in my case uh
the summer time you know every day both
of them i
decided to to try the not for profits
so i was involved with uh
to do not for profits in summertime
still working
as an intern in another entertainment
company you know i decided to
to uh to search to see if that
also was something that would be
interested me
but not my my priority at the end was
entertainment
however it was it was a great decision
that
my summer time is spending trying to do
not for profits with different companies
so it was very valuable for me as well
and then i'm just going through some of
these questions we have a
few more minutes so i'm going to go
ahead and take um
one more here actually this is um
janetta asked something that
steve you had touched upon um
which was how does your mbr prepare for
job
opportunities as bus entertainment
business continues to merge with tech
companies streaming platforms like with
you amazon
mgm disney fox um etc
and steve i'll let you start first but
anyone you know on the panel if they
have an opinion on that feel free to
weigh in
no i think it's very relevant and i
think there is an edge with a stanford
brand for sure
because i think and it may it may be
different in five years or ten years
but right now from now to the next five
years
i think entertainment generally is
shifting and i remember
when people were asking the question
about is netflix a
technology company or a media company
because in the beginning
netflix talked very very geeky right
very tech
about the algorithms and you know the
streaming infrastructure
and but now you know you hear the latest
earnings call
they sound like a studio right and tech
is just a part of what they do
to enable great content to get there so
you know the traditional media companies
like a disney or a fox
uh and you know and of course warner and
all of the different
you know i mean there is no better time
in my view to get into entertainment
than now
because there's so much disruption and
when there's disruption there's
opportunities
you know that's too bad for people who
have a lot of vested interest in the
current status quo
but it's a great thing for new people
wanting to take a new foothold
in an evolving area so i would say if
you're interested in entertainment this
is the
best time to do it and i argue
stanford's the best place that can
prepare you for that because
you have a lot of tech people running
around who don't really understand media
and you also have a lot of media people
who don't understand technology at all
and right now if you position yourself
well at stanford
you sort of already go in with a tech
brand
credibility and if you can fortify that
with content
you know that's a pretty pretty tough
combination to sort of beat
if you're going up against somebody with
those kinds of backgrounds now
it's more than what's on your resume of
course you've got to sort of
go deeper into those insights and what
does that mean but
every tech company is thinking about
media in some way
whether it's their own brand or actual
content uh and every media company is
talking about tech because they have to
to survive in this new world
so um that that's my pitch for
why stanford for media
and did i absolutely believe that
that's a great answer steve anyone else
drop the mic here
how am i supposed to follow that no
i'll just add that uh there are a lot of
people from
the tech side of media companies like
netflix's like product org that come to
a lot of classes and talk about
the tech side of things and and the
business side from like a tech lens
so you you will get some of that
exposure too which is like for marketing
we talked about
you know netflix's approach to um you
know user interface where it's
customizing what titles are displayed
based on who's watching
like that that kind of knowledge is is
really unique too
yeah that is true
yeah well i will add something um
i'm coming from uh
and you know how the right now the the
uh
the tech and the streaming are taking
over you know
uh mostly in mexico and latin american
countries
but i think this is uh following up uh
steve uh this is a great opportunity
this is the
the right moment you know to to be in
stanford you know because you got both
you know you got the the the tech and
you got the
the experience with technology the
technology
and you got the experience also in the
in the media
in the linear production of or whatever
you want to call it
and but it's very important it's very
important because right now the world is
is merging into tech and
media together you know it's not like
used to be
the television before so i think this is
the right moment you know to study
an mba in stanford i think people that
will get exposed you know to all these
opportunities you know in my case i will
i remember right now when i was there um
i met uh
geraldine at that time i was the ceo of
time warner
and he came an offer you know and i
he was my first first year at stanford
he said i want you with me
and also in my not-for-profit marketing
class
i met the director of sales for
univision
and he connected me with he talked about
me with the owner of genevision
and the owner of genovision um uh
called me to set a meeting with him and
the day and i ended
working for generation you know so but
at that time it was not the streaming it
was
nothing like that you know i i wish i
wish i could go back to stamp for now
you know
at this time you know and start again
because this is a great opportunity this
is the moment
yeah we we love hearing these stories um
from you guys to chair
because there's all sort of there's the
um academic curriculum and experience of
course but then there's also just sort
of all of those serendipitous moments
right that
that happen and make the gsb
super special um we have a little bit
less than
10 minutes left we have maybe five
six seven minutes um so what i thought
it was i'd go around to each of our
wonderful panels here
and if you guys don't mind um you know
leaving off with any tips um
considerations um anything that these
uh you know that those are the people
joining us today can expect if they were
here at the gsb
um any sort of final words of
advice or wisdom for those tuning in
today
well i i will start um
i would say that no matter what
background you have
no matter what what was your previous
experience
i mean that is always a plus that is
always
great to have an mba and you guys should
also do some search in the universities
you
would like to consider to take your mba
but definitely stanford will be one of
the first choices
ones that you do you search but
in my case you know i mean it was very
predigious
uh to be a an actor and
and uh pursuing an mba and
so i had a lot of challenges you know
even at home you know
and uh my dad was a rancher he said what
are you going to do with an mba
you stay here you already have a job you
know so
no matter what your background is and
just
if that is your goal go for it and it's
time for a thing will be the first
challenge
the best choice
uh steve do you want to go next oh sure
uh sorry i've got a two and a half year
old in the background
to hear little noises that's my daughter
um you know i think um
i'm just trying to think if i were to
like get in a time machine and go back
to the gsb
what what kinds of things would i tell
myself
and the first maybe two things one is so
cliche
and people said that to me my undergrad
people said that to me the gsb
but it's about you know now i had the
benefit like alberto had like
i draw the trajectory of my classmates
in 07
and i fast forward 14 years and see what
they're all doing now
they're doing amazing things and they're
incredible people
and i guess i wish i had spent more time
also to develop
even deeper even wider friendships with
my classmates
and you know whether it's stanford or
any other
top tier business school you'll have you
know of course great people but i think
at stanford you're going to have
very special people as i said who are
gonna change the world
uh for the better and so you know having
taking that time out
because when you're in it you're gonna
be in the thick of things and
it's like over stimulating because
there's just so many things going on
but to sometimes slow down and really
invest time into friendship
um i think would be something i would
tell myself number one
um and then number two you know some of
the folks i've been
most amazed by are people who take
big pivots um and you know
whether it's like a navy seals guy
coming in and you know becoming
whatever ceo of a completely different
industry that has nothing to do with
defense
uh you know it's just incredible and
you know as some of you guys said like
the mba is the
the most powerful reset button anybody
can give you
so no matter what you were doing before
the mba
you have uh this opportunity to go
completely differently
and i think we live in very exciting
times and
you know you have two years 24 months
if you know exactly what you want you
can chart a path to
when the 24 must come then what company
or what role do you want to be
there's so much there for you to
actually do that or if you don't know
what you want to do
and you want to have the serendipitous
walk stanford is also an amazing place
to do that to kind of continue to talk
to people and get advice and sort of let
let opportunities take you within your
broad framework of your vision
so um anyway i i would say
for either of those models whether you
know exactly what you want to do or you
don't you have no idea what you want to
do
uh you know i think having a place like
stanford
you know talking to alums and talking to
your classmates
um sort of corollary to number one
that's what my word of advice would be
um and there are so many exciting
companies that would love to have a
stanford mba
join their ranks whether it's the you
know
whatever clean up the kitchen or do
corporate strategy or both in the same
day
you know there's so much opportunity so
what an exciting time to be
uh in the mba program steve don't forget
about the weather
as well yeah great
that's right that's right um
mike helen and ally any parting words
for our guests today
um i'm happy to go i would say um come
into the experience very open and say
yes to a lot of things
so be very open to learning about
yourselves very open
to meeting people who are very different
from you and you've never met before
say yes to all the dinners that people
invite you to plan
things to meet a lot of people just come
in like ready to experience a lot of
things you haven't before because that's
what it
what it's all about um be really ready
for that
um i guess i'll just stay on the
admissions process which is
obviously stressful every school you uh
you apply to
um you know especially for me i didn't
have any
big brands on my resume where i could
just have that and knew that would help
me get in
um and that's okay i mean i i think like
gsb really wants to know what your story
is and if you've done things that show
your story and you can tell your story
um
everyone on this this zoom has a shot of
getting in i did not think i would get
in
um and so just remember that and like
really take the time to reflect about
like what matters to you and who are you
and what do you want to do and try not
to get caught up in the
the forums and what your classmates or
other people you're working with they're
doing that have
bigger names on their backgrounds
because there's a lot more that goes
into it than that
yeah i think my biggest piece of advice
for the admissions process is like
spend a lot of time um really thinking
about why you want to
go to business school what you want to
get out of it
um and then stay true to yourself
in terms of like don't write an essay to
intern like
because you think this is what gsp wants
to hear like they can probably smell
through that like you should definitely
reflect and write about what truly
matters to you
and truly why and that should be more
than enough to
you know create a story that resonates
with people
um so i think that's really important um
and then yeah when you're at the gsb be
really intentional with your time
because it really really flies by
so um so say yes to things but also be
respectful of your own
time and energy um and
i i like to like have a list or have
like goals or whatever and check back on
them because time flies and then you're
like
what happened and you want to make sure
you're getting the most out of your two
years too
so thank you to all of our panelists who
joined us today thank you for those of
you guys who tuned in
remember this is just the start of your
journey
if you are ready um to get started we
are
ready for you um we have a ton of more
events
like these coming up throughout july
august september including
application week so speaking to mike and
helen's
a handful of tips about admissions
towards the end here we actually have an
entire week
of programming and workshops the first
week of august
that help you put your best foot forward
so if you guys are thinking about
applying
i encourage you to turn it tune in for
those um
but yeah thank you again for everyone on
the zoom today
and we will hopefully see you guys soon
[Music]
you